all right rebel had a young guy I used
to meet you guys can took a clear it in
see I know she yeah so I'm gonna go all
the flowers that just feel the whole
room yeah so isn't it romantic comes out
in time for Valentine's Day and February
13th yes right before what are your
plans for Valentine's Day at the moment
I'll be filming cats in London basically
now you're not gonna be hanging out with
Liam in my view yeah yeah Simon London I
won't be in London I'm shooting a movie
in San Francisco and I think my
girlfriend's gonna come up and we're
gonna try to go to dinner somewhere I'm
gonna be really cute yeah yeah yeah
that's the issue she's always like just
cuz that's something now is that intense
days like I think more for the girl like
you know it's like we need you to just
step it up a little bit just a little
bit mmm the thing is you know in my life
I'm always doing that okay what I
normally do if you guys could be stuck
in a romantic comedy for the rest of
your life
poof which film would you pick man for
the rest of you live yeah Austin Powers
one oh yeah did you see Austin and Mike
Myers and Elizabeth really there was
some romance there
[Music]
I'm gonna say I'm gonna say Bridget
Jones diary I feel like it it is soil
food I think so
yeah yeah yeah and that's a cool
character I think can i Jerry Maguire
but I'd like to be Jerry oh yeah
then then I'm fine ring stuck I am dude
I won Tom Cruise's life I would say
castaway cuz I like the relationship
with Wilson they have oh no no no Tom
Hanks no one can love one more than Tom
Hanks Wilson oh my god and that's a good
answer
okay most romantic things ever done for
you a ton of stuff I think I think for
me like simply really just Nick being so
embracing of my culture and my family
and his family when they came into India
and just having the two weddings and you
know sort of the amalgamation of what
happened it really created a family
where two cultures came together and you
know celebrated each other and I think
that was just one of the most amazing
things that ever witnessed to see him
doing like he's looked cool and all
those face he wore a turban and a
feather I know it looked awesome I was
there
what yeah yeah it's diamond okay yeah um
I'm trying to think I mean I love
receiving little bits and stuff but I
don't think anyone's done like anything
huge Oh like just little just little
things which I really appreciate a
thoughtful one yeah
those are the best crimes yeah I had
like a big-ass gift with like really
wants to buy me a car no one's ever the
only gifts I usually I like I like candy
so like I know a Mike and Ikes and she
gave me a ten pound bucket of Micah dice
and I had no self-control so I ate ten
pounds of Mike and Ikes in my everyday
and was pretty oh yeah turns out that's
too much again good to know well it was
great to meet you guys
thank you is fantastic so happy
Valentine's Day